software developers we're not known for
our rocking style
are we or are we
today i'll show you how i used ml to
make me trendier taking inspiration from
influencers
i'm gonna build an app that analyzes my
closet and pictures of fashionable
influencers and then makes me outfit
recommendations
if i'm missing an important piece it'll
also recommend me products to buy
let me show you how
[Music]
so the way this is gonna work is that
i'm gonna grab a bunch of fashionable
inspiration pictures from social media
and i'll take a bunch of pictures of my
wardrobe and i'll try to match the
pieces that i already owned those
fashion pictures using machine learning
which will help me put together outfits
i'll wrap this whole thing in a firebase
app
so that i can scroll through outfit
recommendations on my phone all right
let's build this thing
so first i needed to catalog my entire
wardrobe so i thought i could just grab
a few pictures and be wearing clothing
in everyday life and then use computer
vision to pick out the items
to do this i used a feature of the
google cloud vision api called
object detection which identifies
objects and photos and then draws a
little bounding box around them
as you can see it kind of worked it
identified my top
shorts shoes stuff like that but since
i'm going to be matching my clothing
pictures to inspiration pictures
i realized that the quality of my
pictures had to be really high they
couldn't beat at weird lighting angles
or anything like that so i accepted the
sad fate that i was just gonna have to
take a picture of every single item in
my closet
which i did painstakingly over a couple
of days
dressing and undressing my mannequin and
taking pictures of all my different
shoes
next i needed to find some people who
actually knew something about looking
trendy and bonus points if they also
worked in tech
so i reached out to laura medallia laura
is a developer who posts lots of
fashionable outfit pics of herself on
instagram where she's at coder girl
and from head to toe which is important
because we need to capture those shoes
with her permission i downloaded a bunch
of her pictures and uploaded them to
cloud storage
again the goal here is to take a bunch
of laura's pictures and then pictures
from my own closet and see which of her
outfits i can kind of recreate
now challenge one was that not all of
laura's pictures are actually of
clothing
so first i had to eliminate those and
select only the ones where she's in an
outfit
for that i used a feature of the vision
api that does image classification
this feature returns a bunch of tags
describing what in general is going on
in an image
and one of the tags that returns is
fashion so i sorted through all of
laura's pictures and only kept ones that
had a person in them and they were also
labeled fashion
and with that i had my inspiration image
data set
now the next step is to implement the
feature that looks in my closet and the
inspiration picture and matches them
for that i'm going to use yet another
feature of the google vision api
called product search if you're ever
scrolling through a store and you're
looking at a product and you see similar
items
that's the functionality that the google
vision product search feature gives you
so the next step is to create a product
set for this you'll want to use the pi
vision product search library
the first step is to create a product
search client
that connects to the google cloud
backend and next you'll create a product
set where you can hold
all of your clothing items i called mine
dale's closet
next you'll want to go to the spot where
all of your clothing items are stored as
you can see i've got all of mine in a
directory
and if i want to add something like this
black bomber jacket in the code
i create a new product i name it i give
it the category apparel
and then i add any labels that i might
want to later go back and filter by so
just show me jackets and then the next
step is to teach the model what this
bomber jacket looks like
and for that you want to add paths to
all of the different files as reference
images it's better if you can take
pictures from different angles with
different lighting
conditions because it will help the
model generalize better
now to make this a little bit easier for
you i wrote a script in python so that
if you organize your images and
directory structure then you can just
run this script and it will
automatically create a product set for
you
make sure you check out the blog post to
see how once you're done creating your
product set it'll take about 30 minutes
for the api to actually index those
images so just hang tight
when it's finished we get to actually
make outfits with ml to do that we'll
call the search function on the product
search api and pass it a path to an
image file
first it analyzes that image and
identifies any clothing it finds then it
looks through your closet and finds the
best matches
and now here's where it gets interesting
because even though the api returns back
similar
items what we really want are outfit
recommendations
an outfit like has only one pair of
shoes and you can't be wearing a skirt
and pants at the same time
probably so we need to do a little bit
of finagling
and that's kind of par for the course
with ml models they usually don't give
you back exactly what you want so you
have to use your expertise and domain
knowledge to make sure the predictions
make sense
so i'm going to roll my own outfit
algorithm that defines rules for what
pieces of clothing can be in an outfit
and we'll take all of the confidence
scores returned by the api and generate
one new quality score for the entire
outfit
i did all of my outfit making logic in a
python script which wrote out all of my
outfit recommendations to firestore
then i built a little front-end app that
pulls in all the recommendations sorted
in score order
let's take a look at how it did
[Music]
if you want all the details on how i
built this app make sure you check out
the blog post linked below
and follow coder girl on instagram to
get your own neat techie outfit inspo
see you next time
you